always serve before you sell treat
everybody with kindness and respect no
matter how much money you have in the
bank
that has nothing to do with your
self-worth another strategy that i
teach a lot of is
my man what's up bc
so randy garn aka coach everybody just
knows
knows him as coach that's what we call
him uh
i met randy did i meet you in puerto
rico
i we did we actually yeah we spoke
together in puerto rico with uh with
brandon our main yeah
i think i met you though i met you at
growth you know what you did yeah back
agent growth
i wasn't there for as long but i didn't
we didn't really chat much but so puerto
rico
uh is when where where randy and i uh
connected randy is uh
amazing speaker he is he's he's behind a
lot
of the people that you know a lot of the
name brands that you know
randy has had a hand in their success
and uh he's he's got a new book out that
i'm super pumped for
i have it right here i love it
my man that's it we got it here prosper
this is a it's actually it's a you know
it's not this is going to take you
years to read this thing process right
here this isn't your first book though
you've written you've written others
yeah i mean we back in the day we had i
mean we were doing
it was actually bg before google um we
helped a ton
of people come new york best-selling
authors um
we've done just an amazing amount of
things both
online offline with helping authors but
we did we did another book ethan and i
with
kim blanchard they're called one minute
entrepreneur um
and then we did we hit new york times in
2010
and we just thought with everything
going on in the world right now evan
we thought actually it was a good time
to
relaunch prosper back out into the world
update it and get it back out and really
really what we are helping people
understand is
real really what true prosperity mean
it's a balance between money
happiness and sustainability so that's a
that's it's a it's a tremendous message
right now it's going nuts we just hit
number one on amazon this weekend and
it's going awesome man what's different
between
2010 and and i guess 2021 version
you know in 2010 we are just coming out
of if you remember 2009
um there's a little bit different
circumstance in the you know financial
kind of the whole financial meltdown
happened then and we've lived through
we've lived through a lot of a lot of
things you know i'm
i'm one of the ogs i've been in the
personal development space for over 25
years and we've done i've
i've seen a lot and it's really exciting
to see what's happening in the world
today
there's just so much just you know
divisiveness right now
and we you know like you like brendan
like trent
like you know prince prince he just
dropped me an awesome awesome notes
martin luther king day today
and he's just saying he's sending me i
mean an amazing message about just
brotherhood and unity and love
and so i think what's different today
than there was then
it seemed like when we were in a
financial crisis but it seemed like we
were more unified
and i think today i feel like we're more
divided than we've ever been
and i think we need good messengers out
there to help drive
love unity empathy respect
and we cannot have a situation
in our own homes but in our own country
where we're not helping lift and build
each other up to just awesomeness
and that's what we need to get more out
there in the world and so
a lot of what we teach is really
understanding your polaris point like
just seeking clarity on what
what what god or or whatever you believe
has in store for you is important
what do you think is the most important
thing that people could take from this
book
you know right now as they're planning
their new year but
we came from a kind of rough last year
like what what's one simple activity or
exercise you think
everybody needs to go through if it's
polaris or something else from the book
yeah i think i mean we really have six
practices to help you
get some prosperity for you and that's
it right there
but i really think that this last 2020
has been almost like a control alt
delete on a lot of people's lives it's
like
really understanding what's most
important to you in your life
and what is the in you know for me
i used to travel a ton you know i was
always on the plane either speaking or
helping support people or working with
people
and i've got six kids i've got two sets
of twins i've got an amazing wife
for me even even rewriting this was like
dude am i on the right
track am i on the right course
and i think that 2020 has really helped
people do a reset
like a control or delete on what's most
important in their life
and we actually have some practices in
there to really get it dialed in
um one of the practices is are you on
the right path of your true north
one of the things that drives drives
income for you
but that drives fulfillment and joy and
it's sustainable
and because if you're just making a lot
of money we all know a lot of people
that make great revenues and great money
but they're miserable you know we don't
think that that's a state of prosperity
you're just making money you're just
rich
we know a lot of people that are happy
but not driving in any revenues right
and so for us it's actually that balance
when you're making a great income
when you're totally aligned and you have
joy in your heart
and brandon talks a ton about joy too
but it's sustainable if you love what
you do and it's driving in that then you
can do it over long periods of time
i think about you with youtube you've
got a dialed in you know what you love
and you're so freaking good at it evan
you are i mean the best in the world
at being able to help teach and train
people on youtube strategies like you
you're just you've you've owned that and
it's been a career for you and you're
going to continue to get better at that
craft
and so that's really what we're going to
teach teach you is that
like is multi-dimensional and so there's
practices that help you really implement
that in your life
so that's it's super easy and fun is
there a special link people to go to or
just
amazon the usual right now you can get
it digitally for
for i think 99 cents on amazon for i
think today and tomorrow
um but just go to prosperbook.com it
would be an easy one or just you know
you can grab it at amazon as well
so speaking of your uh youtube channel
how we doing on that randy we talked
about it that's this is the year dude
it's on it's all my it's all my it's all
my goals bro
i want to be able to put out content
that lifts and builds people that
helps people develop a life strategy for
themselves and to really create the life
you really want so
uh yeah evan it's it's on you know when
our buddy brendan just hit uh what 100
million plus views on
on youtube and i know i mean you've
helped so many amazing people do that so
this is the year this is the year of
randy and evan right here baby
guys look out what is it just randy garn
what's your youtube channel
dude i've got to get a whole thing set
up coach that's what we need
we got to get we got to get rowdy.com
and get our hands on the meatloaf and
get my uh get my channel cooking bro
that's what we need you don't even know
what that means i love it
uh i love it though dude okay guys stay
tuned 2021 we're gonna have randy
this is one of the guys i've been
pushing every now and then
i sent another dm hey randy come on
what's happening on the youtube side
because there are some people who've got
just
a lot of heart a lot of wisdom a lot of
uh
like if you haven't met randy yet and
and you meet him
and he's he's helping you you all of a
sudden become
just the most important person in the
world to him like this guy cares about
people
and if if you can then bring that to the
big stage on youtube
step one go get prosper prosperbook.com
step two go subscribe to randy's new
youtube channel that
is is launching or is is going to launch
because big things are coming
um do you want to take a couple
questions from my audience i'd love it
it would be i'd love to take a couple
questions from them
uh here we go first question how do you
remain kind
even even after having so much
i think a lot of it has to do with my my
belief
is that i was raised by a father that
was just amazing
and he always taught me that people are
more important than things
and uh for me my greatest assets in life
honestly are me my relationships um
i can only wear one pair of pants i can
only one one shirt so i think it's a
a true understanding of of that
people are the most important asset in
your life and that
everybody whether they're wealthy you
know wealth for me
everybody's completely just amazingly
wealthy they just haven't reached some
of those points yet
and so i think that i think an
understanding that everybody is
has worth is one of the things that i
totally subscribe to in my life
and the other thing is you never know
who i treat and i talk about this a lot
i treat the ceo
and the uber driver the same and evan
knows this about me
it's just like everybody has tremendous
value and they can drive value
you never know who the treasure map to
the treasure is so you never know that
that guy you're sitting in his car
brother may actually be an answer to
your prayers and so
treat everybody with kindness and
respect no matter how much money you
have in the bank
because that's not that has nothing to
do with your self-worth you know
uh randy's one of the guys that i look
up to and i'm not just smalling you know
bloke
that's blowing smoke up while you're
here but as somebody who's made
a kajillion dollars but is still happy
and has a happy family it's like there's
not a lot of people who can say that
and he even just look at his instagram
from yesterday
you know he's got this giant home acres
and acres
but where is everybody the entire family
is
doing some video dancing game uh being
together
his his family like his kids but then
his parents join in and are
dancing with each other and it's just to
have
the financial happiness
as well as the uh relationship
happiness is a combination you don't
often see
right like i've got i've got steve jobs
on my wall
yep kind of financial happiness but not
a lot of
uh you know relationship happiness and i
got my parents who
had a lot of relation happiness but not
that we were poor or anything but not
the not the
biggest loved ones so when i see people
who kind of figured out both was like
ooh
how do i spend more time with them so
you're you're one of the guys like man
that guy he's got to figure that
the answers might be here guys well and
honestly
that's why we wrote about that is
because i've worked with highly highly
net worth
individuals you know i'll work with
several ceos a year and help them
with this strategy and i talk a lot
about the home court advantage
and the home court advantage to me is
like if everything's not right at home
it's hard to be as successful as you can
in business and you want to drive
respect for people and that's why
that's why we did write this is to kind
of model after the kind of life
i wanted to create and back when i wrote
this in 2008
i wasn't in a financial state i am now
i've been totally blessed
i wrote this book because i actually
wanted to create this type of life
and for those that that know me i can
irrevutably say that you know i have
an amazing wife great kids but i also
have
my best friends or my business partners
and i think that's the other thing
that's really interesting about it
is who do you work with what do you
where do you go to every single day
i always said to myself a lot of people
say oh never work with your friends
i have only worked with my best friends
why would you go to spend half your life
with people that you hate build a
company and a business with people that
you love like and respect
and that was actually one of my big
polaris points
in my life i want to have a life filled
with joy success productivity
and and uh just all the way around the
board so that's another another strategy
that i
teach a lot of is work with people that
you love
i love it i i mean i work with my wife
now and i've worked with
lots of my friends over the years i i
really deeply love it i think it's just
about being able to communicate
properly yeah i think you have a hard
time separating out the emotion
and being able to actually have real
conversations with the people in our
lives
so this was written with ethan willis
there was another just amazing human
who i'm trying to push to make more
youtube videos because we got to see his
content out there too
how do you how do you what's your advice
for working with family or working with
your spouse or working with your friends
again i think it's it's an understanding
of having
um ensuring that they're competent
ensuring that they that that you have
very clear expectations of each other
and you know i really teach a lot about
also about
a strategy called the uac understand
agree
and commit and i learned this from my
one of my partners tyler tyler norton
was that
if you too many times we commit to stuff
that we don't fully understand
and we don't fully agree disagree to so
it always ends up bad
um and so i always any time that i'm
doing a new partnership or a
relationship with anybody i want to make
sure that our
our ethics are aligned that actually we
know each other's goals they may be
different and that's okay
but at least we have a very very clear
understanding of that so agree
you know you ac understand agree and
then commit
is a really really big thing of that
that everybody should do in all their
relationships
the first guy i hired was my best friend
and i had to fight he wasn't very
confident at what at what i wanted him
to do which i think is part of the
problem he's very competent but not what
i wanted him to do
and i think a lot of people end up
losing friendships because they don't
know how to communicate properly
and they're not respectful in the
conversation and
anyway i just think it's amazing what
you built with the people you've built
and again it's something that
as i look at your career and everything
you've done it's like okay i'm taking
notes i'm taking notes from my coach we
gotta we gotta make it happen
angela is asking what does prosper
mean to you why did you title your book
prosper for me um
the book title is really we really dove
into did a ton of research we did
you know thousands of thousands of
studies about what does
the what does prosperity mean to someone
and we really came to understand that
it's like i said it's like it is a true
balance between
money making money is totally awesome
like really when you're when you're
successful and you're
able to do that you know i think russell
brunson um
posted today and i really love it he
said that it's much easier to make 10
grand than it is to save 10 grand
and i totally agree with that because i
don't want people to think that
prosperity doesn't have anything to do
with money it does
but it just has to mean that the income
and the money that you're making
is aligned with what drives value and
joy for you
in your life so it's money plus
happiness
plus and then sustainability can you do
it over long periods of time and does it
make you grow
and is it drive value for those that
you're that you're
teaching training products or services
that you're offering
so it's really those three things money
plus plus happiness and joy
plus sustainability equals prosperity in
all of the research that we did
you know we we've done we've ran the
largest one-on-one coaching and training
company
in the world we had thousands of of
customers 80
000 plus students and that was from from
that the research that he says like
what does this mean and this means like
are you really living the life that you
want to live
and i think that's it really comes down
to a really good we do have some
practices in there but really
understanding those three points that's
what prosperity is
okay let's see what else we got we got
uh trent who's asking how do you push
yourself
even when the deck is against you in
some way
is that trent jones that's mr jones
right there i love it
how do you do that when the deck is
against you i think
i mean one of the things is what we talk
about it's actually one of the chapters
in the book is to start with what you
already have
and a big part of my whole entire life
has been
find out what assets do an inventory of
what you already have what your skill
sets are what your competencies are
a big one is once you understand what
you want once you understand your north
star and your polaris point
is then you gotta start with what you
already have
i i promise you every time i've done
this people have a lot more than they
think they have
and one of the tools that i teach on
in this is who are the top five to ten
relationships that you need to have
because sometimes it's not
money that you need it's actually cells
or relationships more than that
and knowledge and expertise and so
if you have certain relationships or you
need to go get them
make a list of the top five to ten
people that will make the most
meaningful impact in what you want to
accomplish
and then find a way to build a
relationship with them too many of too
many of us have financial goals and too
many of
you know we have financial goals fitness
goals but do we have relationship goals
of people that we want to do business
with so that's what i would start with
taking an inventory of what you already
have
what what would your relationship uh
advice be
for for kind of business relationships
because i'm
you seem great at it um i'm super
introverted and hate like
hurricane and stuff and brendan had to
ask me multiple times to
to do the puerto rico thing mostly
because i'm worried that
i don't know i'm going to disappoint
people or just not
not you know what am i going to t i'm
going to teach randy and brendan
burchard how to believe
right and like what am i gonna why am i
here um
so for people who might be introverted
or shy or
uh scared of that stuff what would you
recommend them to do
to build those relationships um so
again you too you have to get strategic
with it
and i think some of this like here's a
good example
um there was a ceo that i really admired
a ton
and we were and this was back in 2007
and we were we were trying to work on uh
getting a really really really good
business deal with them
and so i found out what meant a lot to
him i found out that his son his 11 year
old son had leukemia
and that they were huge yankees fans and
so what i
what we did was i actually got a signed
autographed
ball for from jeter not for him but for
his son
and so i think in those relationships
like what
find out what matters to them
and and always serve before you sell
always serve before you sell and so i
did that and then we've
i still have an amazing relationship
over the years any
and he has that his son has that ball
sitting there and he always reminds me
about that forever
so i think be unique never be boring
never be predictable
with your relationships and i think to
find that out people are just sharing
all the time
on instagram on social media what's
going on
yeah right so i mean when i when i had
my book coming out randy was the first
guy to say hey how do i order
a case of them how do i get them
what's the offer just send me the link
and i'm in
because at that time you know the book
was the most important thing that i was
talking about so um do you like
keep track i don't know how you stay on
top of are you you're just so good at
how you stay on top of all your
relationships and kind of remember
everybody and what to do for them
what is just whatever comes to mind are
you how do you be more strategic with it
so i do i i mean as
my business has grown i do have an
amazing
chief of staff that manages all my
birthdays manages all of that
and so but also i have on my phone
i have i guess i'm on my phone right now
i have my top 25 list
of people that are most important to me
and that that i will and you know
our beach gang is just an amazing group
of humans
and it's it's i've i've learned that as
i've gotten
older in life my real core friends have
gotten smaller but bigger in value
and and drive more influence but i still
have i have my core
freaking powerhouse team of trusted
advisors and friends
then i have my tribe people that i can
reach out to and then you have your
followers and fans or whatever that may
be and so i think as you go through life
we can't be and i talk about it's a
little bit the difference between like
snorkeling and scuba diving
my core group of friends like i know
what's going on in their life i know who
they are
i think about them and i don't know i
just i just naturally have always
just loved people and been very
interested in them and i think
to be interested you you will become
interesting and so
i do have a little bit of a strategy um
i'll watch for stuff on
online i'll watch for stuff on facebook
or instagram hey i ran into an issue
i'll shoot a quick video and say hey
great job
i mean prince did it today i haven't
talked to prince in like a month and he
just
sent me a freaking awesome awesome voice
message to just pump me up
and let him know that we're thinking
about that he let him know that he's
thinking about me and so
it's those little things that will that
will help you really make a difference
in your relationships
don't don't just snorkel scuba dive with
them i thought you were going to give me
a fishing or horseback riding analogy
because that's
if you ever look at randy's stuff it's
always fishing and horseback riding
i love it well dude it's crazy how time
flies we're having fun it's basically a
year ago that we first connected in
puerto rico and it's crazy that we're
not back there but
once things once we get through all this
uh guys go pick it up
prosperbook.com uh on the youtube side
we're gonna link it up in the
description you can go check it out get
your copy
dude i'm so pumped for you i can't wait
for your youtube content too
thank you for um for popping in sharing
your love your wisdom and
and prosperity with my audience well
evan thanks for the goodness that you
bring to the world and uh
you're just an amazing human i'm
grateful for you
thank you for the love see you bye
everybody see you soon
if you want to see the one-on-one i did
with tony robbins check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there the quality of
your life has nothing to do with how
much money you have on any beautiful
children you have how many people love
you
the quality of your life is where you
live emotionally this is the time to
retool
it's a time for you to say where's the
world now where do i think it's going